allez allez
concentration maximale pour les 450
joueurs et joueuses présents ce jour-là
au centre national d'entraînement de
Clairefontaine ces sportifs participent
à la Saint-Gobain Football Cup c'est
final organisé du 21 au 23 avril
regroupe les meilleures écoles
d'ingénieurs et de commerce de France le
niveau est très élevé pour être honnête
là on sait que il y a vraiment pas le
droit à l'erreur le niveau est très très
fort en face mais c'est stimulant du
coup il y a un bon esprit de compétition
je trouve et un bon fair-play du
fair-play mais aussi des rivalités entre
les structures sur le terrain les 24
équipes venues des quatre coins de la
France veulent gagner pour leur école
c'est un peu comme le derby ou le derby
le classico entre Paris et Marseille
quoi on sent qu'il y a une recherche de
victoire une envie de gagner et puis
surtout de gagner ici à Clairefontaine
au-delà de l'aspect sportif l'événement
aussi pour objectif de faire rêver ses
étudiants depuis 11 ans les
organisateurs investissent ce lieu
d'entraînement de l'équipe de France
cette année pendant 3 jours la magie a
une nouvelle fois opérée on a toutes les
deux joué en club on toutes les deux
faits du foot pendant longtemps c'est
une expérience qui est vraiment unique
je pense que c'est un privilège d'être
là et on s'est battu pour être là avec
notre équipe en école c'est génial il y
a les super installations à chaque fois
quand on regarde les rassemblements des
Bleus on voit les joueurs et débarquer
sur les fameuses escaliers on est
l'opportunité de visiter les locaux de
s'entraîner de voir ce que vous pouvez
vivre les joueurs à la cantine tout en
fait on a même des kinés qui sont là
disposition pour nous masser l'étudiants
c'est assez fabuleux cette onzième
édition a sacré l'INSA Lyon chez les
hommes et les femmes pour les ingénieurs
pour les écoles de commerce les deck
Lille chez les filles et Grenoble chez
les garçons l'emportent rendez-vous
l'année prochaine pour une nouvelle
édition dans les Yvelines